good morning Millennials and happy
birthday to you love me happy birthday
to me happy birthday Queen Claudia Oh
I mean if everyone else cuz it was gonna
get the joy of me seeing them happy
birthday I might as well also get it on
my words that was pretty good that was
the best it ever went
I'm national anthem babe you know I'm
holding out for my own birthday of
course for other people money you have
to save the best for your so I'm not
gonna give them like the Marilyn Monroe
mr. president please don't please don't
we apologize for running about six
minutes late but at 10:29 I stumbled
upon the greatest of America's Got
Talent audition probably of all time and
I had to see it through because he got
the golden buzzer spoiler alert his name
is Luca Islam he's literally the most
precious gem of a man he's so [ __ ]
cute and not only that the talent
supreme and I have to finish it sorry
Julie enough gave him the golden buzzer
love julianne hough for recognizing
Talent no totally I watched it last
night and I was crying do you guys know
that song she used to be my my cerebral
it's from waitress right I'm just so
[ __ ] sad and then with Luke is I'm
singing it like it's just so cute and
they played if you have a white sounds
like a sad song it is like I I don't
know what it's about cuz I've never seen
the play but it sounds like about
someone who died I need to know know
what do I need to know you wanted to
know something you want to talk about
waitress oh yes can you talk about
waitress sure do you know that they cast
colleen ballinger as waitress yeah who's
that I'm todrick Colleen ballinger
lipstick Miranda Sanderson okay she's
does she sing okay I saw commercial and
she has an amazing voice and her entire
car the stars
I love waitress for like leaning into
the digital space no waitress is always
pretty cool like katharine McPhee was in
rate Tracy I'll settle was in the
original
yeah obviously sir
obviously Sara Bareilles I'm here for it
or there's someone else and the pie
looks good is there any ads is there
like a chubby funny girl who who can
really sing very well like is there a
character in that show that I should
bite
why don't you see a TV I don't know like
a Tracy Turnblad character I don't looks
like a waitress who works like the nice
[Music]
I don't know needs come back I'm broad
right because like I will try out yeah
well you missed your calling to trial
for hairspray live which was an open
casting and like it was when I was at my
absolute fattest and I think right now
look at I actually think I'm she's
getting to be trekking above I think so
I think so which leg is great but the GP
[ __ ] for the role would you be up for
any role I don't think so I ought to
seem like I had such a hard time losing
weight like I could never go back to
what if it was a role like it was even
like once upon a time in Hollywood in
you knew like you're going to the Oscars
the Grammys like you're in like it to
lose weight before the Grammys and I'm
scared course you only have to be big
for the film and will I get like
Hollywood training chef drugs like I
won't at all Oh to lose the weight no
only good to gain the weight on a
Hollywood budget that's exciting
yeah I mean I can do it in half the time
yeah I know so you don't even need
budget to get like to gain weight no I
mean I do it for free
eating healthy that's expensive yeah
okay I would do it though okay would you
but what are we saying leaving out 50
pounds yeah 50 pounds that's a lot on a
small girl that's where I was before
yeah would you go back to that place but
and then they also have to be on screen
in that place yeah and remember turn up
place I don't think so really you would
turn now to a list Cannes Film Festival
that's right Becca that's it oh I want
to be Sundance Film Festival that's not
the fame of one of you I want to be like
Kristin Cavallari levels of Fame we're
like I might get paparazzi and every now
and then but I can still live a normal
life with my kids but also I make a lot
of money in limited mansion in a show
okay so you want a reality show that's
where she's at no but I don't want a
reality show I'm just saying I want that
level of Fame she has a really good
level okay well good luck we're working
on it but also it's because she lives in
Nashville and like there's less
paparazzi there you know she lives on a
farm
it's not like she'd be paparazzi every
day oh you think like going to get her
juice yeah hmm okay well I get stuff to
stay in New York welcome to New York
speaking of oh my god
okay so um if you held me at Instagram
you know that I did have to reschedule
my birthday dinner from tonight to last
night because yesterday I got invited to
the prime to a concert I'm like I just
can't believe it like what is life me
and Margo are going to have a teen
ballroom tonight and we're just like the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up we're [ __ ] [ __ ] up I
had a tailor inspired dress for Vegas
but [ __ ] that I'm wearing it tonight so
I was like I have a buyer dress I don't
know when we meet you tell me what you
do where your retro feet that's so
Taylor again
I can't you just keep talking about it
but you've only worn it like three times
lot of money on a dress I'm like Tiffany
Haddish like I'm wearing it everywhere
like I remember that you know that bomb
nan dress that you have that we both
wear like all the time that I were to
TPG awards that they both wear all the
time that's no I think I said that yeah
yeah and you left I wear all the time
nope okay yeah we're all it's Margo's
dress that I heard but it's like I
remember when I wore it someone was like
- these girls ever take off this dress
and it's like no we paid a lot of money
for it I'm totally well I was thinking
like should I go for like a cute concert
outfit with my Taylor merch or like come
in the red carpet like no unless you
could wear Taylor merch with heels and
like make it fancy no don't go looking
like a concert with a backpack at number
something tied around your but I'll be
stuntin on these hoes yeah you'll be
sitting on these nails if you I don't
know I tailored t-shirt that's long that
you could wear with boots
I'd allow it okay I'll look into what
the box said I got I'll do what you all
do what you do yeah okay that's so
exciting and I mean that's really cool
for you but I got invited to an acoustic
set of Third Eye Blind so I'm gonna be
there to bed which is I don't know it's
it for been like a third I got Third Eye
Blind tibetans Taylor to me yeah so
we're having a blending sponge night out
while it obviously sounds pretty fun it
does and then it's so excited it's so
intimate so intimate and then it's like
it sounds cool it's cool vibe and it's a
cool place like I'm just gonna do
everything a manageable amount
imaginable to like get backstage and
like just take a really quick picture
with Taylor like I Wango Tango they were
people that say she took a picture with
how to be yeah like I'm just gonna be
aggressive okay but like not you don't
want to see her no it seems like I'm
trying to be my friend
so like you're running into the squad no
I feel like in this case like you have
to put your your fandom or your third
chest yeah you know like I'm gonna be
honest I don't know if the friendship if
it's gonna happen no I mean like it's
not so I might look at least get a
picture yeah I believe mean that happen
with Kim like when I got a picture with
Kim Kardashian I was an absolute beast
and I literally in that moment cemented
the fact that like I'll never be friends
with him because she gave me friends
with beasts no this is fine that's like
when we go to concerts and like semis we
don't want to go backstage cuz it's like
- I don't like when we were huge - like
it would have like I would have I'm not
trying to eat oh yeah I was trying to be
a fan of Jackman like if I will I I will
bow down and just and wait on a meet and
greet yes yeah I'll wait I mean realign
but I went I mean a great line for Brett
Eldredge best ten seconds of my life oh
yeah
those pictures are hurried horrendous
you were writing the dress oh yeah yeah
oh man that's so buddy well it's not
time so no it's not I don't say that it
is how are you feeling 25
quarter-century
I feel fine honestly like I feel the
same way I do every year like a big dope
do you know what I mean yeah there's
something dopey about your birthdays
when like everyone's being nice to you
it's like just be a regular you know
yeah I've been pretty regular like it
takes you 45 nothing crazy you know
you've been regular but this birthday is
extra dopey because you're taking over
an entire week no I know
so start it on Tuesday because Miley and
it's ending on Sunday because we're
gonna Vegas okay well I just I want to
put it out there like I don't want to be
treated like the birthday girl like I
just really want everyone to have a good
time okay it's hard you know no like for
real like I know everyone's taking time
out of their lives paying money to fly
and comfor me so like I want everyone to
act like it's their trip like it is it's
not my trip I just really wanted to go
to Vegas to not even any be like famous
last words juxtaposed with her in the
club it's my birthday you know I was
thinking today like should I be a
monster but like I'm a monster usually
so why don't I change it up and don't be
a monster that's cool yeah like be a
nice birthday feel you've never been
like it's my birthday let you do that
yeah exactly so I don't it's not like
we're going for me yeah yeah no I really
don't intend on being a monster unless
like you know people aren't falling into
lying yeah unless like people aren't
turning up like that is the only thing
I'll be annoyed about because like I
spent so much time and money planning
this trip like and I just want everyone
to arrange their faces off so obviously
people like in the club like sit
waiting to go waiting for me to be ready
to go home let go home yeah okay I'm
gonna remember that
no sorry don't go home turn up yeah what
if I can't turn up I should go home I
feel are you planning on not turning but
sometimes you just get you hit a wall
yeah if you hit a wall like I don't want
you moping around but don't take people
down with you no I'm Irish eggs and yeah
I don't say anything I need to clip this
segment to everyone who's coming yeah
that's good or they should be watching
the choices they're a true friend that's
true well Lauren Elizabeth is on a plane
so I forgive her because she can't be
watching but she's coming I'm so excited
like I just feel like we got a real
ragtag group of kids we have a great
crew we have a great career we have
group chat I really invited anyone I'm
like if you want to take the time out of
your life and spend money on a flight
like you are more than welcome to
celebrate me I'm through my friends come
through well it's exciting
it has don't say that house Theo
handling your birthday I mean he's
definitely feeling the lack of attention
like and it's getting Tim cuz he too is
just like his mother big diva but I'm
gonna get from him yet which is so
[ __ ] but maybe he wants to wait till
later in the day yeah I mean I got all
my presents yesterday which is like so
stupid cuz I don't get any presents
today do you get anything good oh I got
everything good like I really you know
when you get so many gifts like you feel
unworthy awful yeah yeah I felt like a
piece of [ __ ] I got so many gifts and I
really loved them all so much and I
tried to show that like I've given
people camps where like they might have
liked them but like they didn't show it
you know so I tried to be like extra
with my like opening faiths like oh you
didn't yeah cuz I really did like the
gifts and I wanted people to know like I
appreciate the money and like the effort
put forth in this gift we appreciate
that you appreciate that right no I've
given someone a gift that I've been
really thoughtful about and they like
like it but they're like I'm gonna thank
you on to the next one look so I want to
save her in the moment of this one gift
yeah also it was actually hard to buy
you a gift this year because usually
like gift is gift but we are going to
Vegas you you're you had said you didn't
want anything like super crazy so it's
like I'm not gonna it was just hard to
find something like nice and thoughtful
but not so yeah you know I mean I did
ask for one thing and didn't get it and
that was just like some low yield bonds
a couple stocks some stock options I
like him and nobody gave that to me like
I got a box from it was like Louboutin
and I'm like there better be stocks in
here Louboutins LVMH yeah yeah yeah okay
yeah you dream big my friend
dream baby I may be one
fifteen million dollar stocks no but go
use Robin Hood totally this is not an
atom no but it could be okay feeling
like maybe it's time I mean why would
its 10:46 already like we started late
because of oh right okay so badly if you
haven't watched a video like I don't
watch America's Got Talent
sometimes I catch the golden bother
buzzers for like grace Vander Waal and
Susan Boyle um
you have to watch Lucas I'm like I'm I
cried I was crying because the song and
him and his reaction when he gets
positive feedback it's just like it's
too much no it's it's him like his voice
is obviously like next level incredible
but like the way that he looks he's so
[ __ ] precious looking he's like this
little kid like he's so innocent and
piece of Peter and all he wants is to be
a Broadway star which is so precious
intention totally it's not like I want
to be a record label you know right his
rapper hit the casting go to the club
it's like I wanna be on Broadway like a
real talent show men the very showman he
is check it out it's really it's worth
it okay without further ado it is now
time for the past five stories that you
need to know before you wake up and take
a bite out of Claudia's birthday cake
but before we do I'd be remiss if I
didn't tell you that today's episode is
brought to you by paint your life do you
have an original painting of yourself
and your children your family a special
place or a cherished pet at a price you
can afford
from paint your life calm Jackie just
got one I just won I sent in one of my
wedding photos let's get in front of our
pink flower wall because I wanted a pink
painting and they send you back like a
draft and at one point like my nose
looked a little big and I had like a
greasy slick so I was like can we
and that's Jen like hello and they do
the edits and then it's a back-and-forth
you tell them exactly what you want and
then it comes at it's literally [ __ ]
Monet no I have like a mural of theö
paintings I've gotten over the years
from people at shows things I purchase
and paint your life was the most
customizable experience I was like you
know feels looking a little pale yeah
can we make him a little tanner and you
can get it framed you can get whatever
size you want and it's really like
artwork but you don't have it's an
elevated personalized it's personalized
but it's more elevated than having this
photo
in your house I agree it makes the
perfect gift for birthdays or
anniversaries you choose the artists
whose work you most admire and you work
with them throughout the process until
every detail is perfect there's no risk
if you don't love the final painting
your money is refunded it's great for
jcore it's a fun work of art with paint
your life and right now as a limited
time offer you can get 30% off your
painting that's right
30% off and free shipping to get this
special offer text the word toast TOA st
- 47 47 47 that's toast two four seven
four seven four seven again that's text
toast TOA st two four seven four seven
four seven i love it
get it for yourself get it as a gift for
someone it's super personal and super
cute okay now it's time yeah first story
we teased it yesterday but i got to read
in the full article last night ariana
grande reveals in vogue interview that
she doesn't remember thank you next
Ariana's closest friends new recording
new music would be one of her only forms
of Solace following Mac Miller's death
okay so Ariana Grande is on the cover of
Vogue with a little dog with her dog and
a full spread what's the call the
centerfold and the centerfold when it's
porn no I know okay the interview was
actually quite interest on so here's
some of the highlights pointing out that
jungle City Studios was around the
corner from her apartment her friends
brought her there in the hopes of
helping her grieve for the late 26 year
old rapper quote my friends know how
much solace music brings me so I think
it was an all around let's get her there
type of situation she said in the cover
story unfortunately or maybe it was for
the best memories of the sessions that
led to thank you next album are blurry
at best but if I'm completely honest
quote I don't remember those months of
my life because I was a so drunk and be
so sad grande who appears on the cover
alongside her dog Toulouse explained
quote I don't really remember how it
started or how it finished or how all of
a sudden there were ten songs on the
board that is so crazy that's wildly
interesting and very brave of her to
open up because people really hear mr. a
but like everyone grieves in their own
way and if she wants to drink and
blackout then that's her prerogative no
totally the interview was so interesting
because we talked about her a lot on the
show her mental state like her touring
the way that she feels and she
is so aware of all of that and like she
said that she started touring again
because people were like you need a
schedule because she just had been
through yes so much like grief and
disaster that she just needed something
to distract and like just keep her on
track and she says like sometimes I do
shows and I'm just like broken and the
fans feel it they know everything that
I'm feeling I'm like that's fine and
there we're all in this together and I
actually thought it she did a really
good job of representing herself she
spoke really well about a lot of
subjects especially Manchester it just
was like heartbreaking to read because
she was like I don't even like talking
about it because it's not even my
tragedy like right it's for these
parents and like these children and she
was like we did one love Manchester and
we raised a lot of money but we didn't
bring anyone back like we didn't
accomplish anything and it was just like
she's so in tune and self-aware yeah and
well she sounds very mature but it's
unfortunate how self-aware she is
because there's so much to be aware of
right and it's so much bad things to be
aware of art can't be contributing
positively to her mental state and it
was like just when she was you know
coming to terms with Manchester she's
releasing sweetener then she's engaged
to Pia Davidson and Mac Miller guys and
like that-like de tragedy on top of tyre
to be like it just broke her yeah you
know she's definitely a broken woman but
she's I feel as if maybe she's very
stable like in a lot of ways in a lot of
ways she is because she's aware of how
fragile she is and I feel it's like she
quit it's scary when people are so
fragile but they don't know how fragile
they are and that like they could be set
off by anything yeah and you know who
she was reminding me a little bit of
Bethany where it's like bad things keep
happening she's such a strong like
fierce person like a force to be
reckoned with but like can't catch a
break no totally that's a great
comparison the article ends actually in
a kind of funny way she talks about
therapy whatever and she's like actually
do you have a good snack of this but
it's like I feel like everything she's
been through is above stuff anyone's
paygrade it's like this is not what they
teach you in archaeological school
therapists school versus sociology
majors do they teach you that no no just
what you said about Pete though that was
wildly interesting what did she say she
said that he was a distraction and but
like that she was like it was completely
unrealistic I love
I didn't know him like just everything
we thought duh she said I don't know why
like I still hold out hope for them like
I don't think they were so mismatched I
think the timing was awful and like yes
it was too hot too fast but like I feel
like in another world yes work I reckon
world if they had met in a more
traditional way and like had more of a
regularly scheduled relationship it
probably could have worked out like I
didn't think the pairing was so
mismatched I just think the media frenzy
and like the scheduling of it all was so
weird and the tattoos and it was all so
untimely they'd had choose him on the
late night show the Instagram comments
like they needed to real it that's why
when people doing you're in a
relationship people tell you to take it
slow yeah because then that's what
happens if you do that was like a true
stereotype you know yeah and like six
months later she realized this is wrong
in an article you know yeah and maybe
like an in Mack dying I was just like
the cherry on top I think yeah and maybe
if he hadn't they would have had a
chance to get up like on solid ground
and I feel like Ariana can really never
get to a healthy place just because like
I mean I follow Ariana and I think I
follow like one or two fan accounts and
then in my explore page it's like all
the fan accounts because they think I'm
like an ariana grande's Stan and the
amount of content that she must get
infiltrated with on all social media
networks of like really cute old videos
of like her and Mac and just like edits
like relax there's no way to ever move
on when you're inundated with content
like that that it's literally just
visuals of what's going on in your head
yeah she actually is hilarious and like
low-key really shady because she was
talking about social media and how she
has to get off of it because she's like
too expressive whatever and she was like
I'm not gonna take like a corny break
for social media where I'm like social
media is the devil yeah no that's and
that's it authentic ya know and that's
so [ __ ] corny or so you called it
cheesy yes that's exactly what it is she
but you do need a break even me like
sometimes my wrists hurt I need if I can
bring carpal tunnel season that's wrap
my phone like yesterday for just like
the east timing everyone I was just like
on my phone too much I just threw it
away but then I do that all the time I'm
gonna check my screen time from
yesterday Oh scary last seven days how
do you just see yesterday I don't know I
just get like on a daily report my hours
per day eight hours I don't think that's
so bad that's pretty bad justify it is
like you
to eight hours in the day yeah it's work
what's yours margarita day really if
mines worse in Margo's I'm gonna die how
do I check for yesterday crest last
seven days it's just an average what's
yours four hours and 57 minutes wait let
me check mine what app is it it just go
to settings set anyone help you hold on
hold a screen time last seven days hold
on where do i click that scroll up it
looks different than mine hold on I go
like this do you guys ever do this like
I only got that update with my new phone
and I didn't know that five hours in
nine minutes
oh my guess I'm working harder than you
know it's wrong I'm seven I'm eight
hours No
I'm working harder than today yeah bar
your PA like your job you're looking
five hours but if maybe it's on the iPad
everyone share yours so we can feel
better oh yeah but last time I checked I
was seven
so maybe I'm just having an off week
also it's been two days of this week
bless seven days oh my god Wow Margo
that was oh it's because of when I was
in our court I had no service I was not
have my phone at all where's a pen
justify like we got it you're not sure
Jen's ear there's nothing to be about
yes about even though we did hire you as
our token Jen's ear so we can like tap
into a young girl right let's talk about
this at the end of the week or and now
you're not really accomplishing that so
let's talk about this at the end of the
week all right we'll talk at the end of
the week I'll talk at the end of the
week all right anyways I highly
recommend reading this vogue article
because it's full of interesting
factoids so they didn't already know
whereas that's not always the case ya
know as she says she seemed to like open
up it wasn't like a publicist standing
in the corner coughing every time she
said something inappropriate you know
yeah I like when you can really feel
like an artist opened up there was no
walls and Ariana's not one to like spill
her heart all the time so I really I'm
enjoying this I'm enjoying I'm not crazy
about the cover now no I'm not crazy
about the cover at all you like to loose
looks like he was photoshopped yes her
laughs oh this looks so weird she looks
like she's in front of a green screen no
this looks like an Instagram post I
really am NOT happy with it and her
style and her hair is so iconic like why
cover that up with a hat agreed and this
is just so not her yeah it's so not her
that's how it let me show them and it
also just the dog looks so weird like
I'm not
like the and she has an amazing body
like there's so much more we could have
seen here yeah
do you see um Serena Williams on the
cover of Harper's Bazaar yes Oh iconic
iconic this has made a little bit better
when you know that this Beach is the
beach where she grew up it's in like
Boca that's what I learned in the
article okay so it's at her home so show
us in her house yeah I don't not here
for it yeah it's the article like the
physical magazine out yeah I think it's
about to come out yeah see there's other
pictures I wonder if she did 73
questions son she had they're definitely
waiting for this and then they'll do
seven three questions to get the next
press like yeah that's yeah yeah okay
ready for all that story yeah really
crazy manager says ASAP Rocky is being
held in inhumane Swedish prison I heard
this is a crazy story ASAP Rocky is
being held at a Swedish prison with
quote inhumane conditions following a
street fight in the country according to
the rappers manager who is petitioning
for the stars release quote the
conditions of the facility or horrific
manager John Eman wrote in a new
change.org petition titled quote just
hashtag justice for Rocky wait I'm sorry
you're one of the biggest artists in the
world you have a manager who's so
well-connected like two different
powerful people and you're turning to
change stuff right you're turning to the
people when like you're have more power
than any of us yeah like those Hollywood
management agencies like they can really
like they can they're seriously
connected like yeah where's Arnold
Schwarzenegger I don't know the Swedish
government has much respect so change
the border I don't know if change.org
holds jurisdiction in Swedish no in
Sweden so it's hashtag justice for rocky
demand that Rocky be released by Swedish
officials and then went on to claim that
there's 24/7 solitary confinement
restriction of amenities for the most
basic of human functions access to
palatable and life-sustaining food as
well as unsanitary conditions that's
awful the music exec called for fans to
sign a petition in on Instagram after
the Swedish Supreme Court denied an
appeal for Rocky's release I guess it's
more so a publicity thing like we're
talking about it because there's a
petition right and like powerful people
in America will feel obligated to
comment on it or do something if there's
a good strong urging from the community
yeah but it just seems like he could be
you know pursuing other avenues
maybe he is but this is just one of them
that's awful and I heard that there's a
video of the street fight and it's he
was attacked first did the whole thing
is crazy earlier this month authorities
said rocky had been detained over a
suspected attack the rapper shared a
video of the incident on July 2nd and
said the fight went down after drug
addicts hassled him some friends and a
security guard on the street
Edmond said Rocky's and his team acted
in self-defense after they were harassed
and physically assaulted so this whole
thing is an awful story shady I don't
think there's anything scarier than
being held in a foreign prison oh my god
I couldn't agree more also like Sweden
what's with the inhumane prison
conditions like aren't you supposed to
be neutral bro no totally it doesn't
sound very new to me no neutral would be
you know everyone has a toilet and three
meals a day yeah maybe some outside
recreational time and swedish fish of
course of course free um I don't know
how we can help other than signing the
petition but this needs to get done
because very sad especially because it
doesn't even deserve to be in jail in
the first place right I mean that's just
life but right but like there's a video
ya know one it's like where is the trial
innocent until proven guilty
that cool ground yeah so justice for
ASAP truly do I want a justice ASAP yeah
just to say sup for a SAP yeah we could
be like the marketing team behind this
whole campaign that's making about us or
anything no but here we are making it
about us okay this third story is
equally upsetting is this a story you
were like teasing me before the show
with yeah I don't know if you're ready
for it scary stuff or maybe already know
it and now I'm like hyping it up but
Cole Swindell and Barbie blank have
split three months after making their
red-carpet couple debut Wow
I'm devastated oh my god don't talk to
me for a month what country singer Cole
Swindell and professional wrestler
Barbie blank first confirmed their
relationship in April attending the 2019
ACM Awards together just three months
after making their debut as a couple the
country singer and professional wrestler
have decided to end their relationship
People magazine confirms Swindell and
blank first confirmed their relationship
in April it sounds like you're saying
it's like an ad lay yeah like mad libs
sorry I couldn't Allen down ad name here
okay there's no reason
and I just you know what this is a
perfect way for them to end mysteriously
and without reason because that's how
they got together mysteriously and we
never found out having Matt like there
was no reason for them coming together
so you know what it seems I propel it
does but I'm really upset like I just
thought this was magic no I thought this
was it and she had just posted last week
at a country first of all like some
cowboy yes festival where she was in
like the most epic the town you a dress
up you were dating a country singer and
I had her body yeah yeah no she isn't
amazing and I was just like she's all in
in the country world and now she's all
out that is so sad I feel like I put a
lot of eggs in this basket I did too I
never considered that they might break
up and so soon well you know it's so
hard when you're dating a musician who's
on tour especially clothes from Dell is
like so up-and-coming he's on every
concert ever so I mean I have to assume
that the scheduling what had to be a
contribution to that I'm not gonna say
that we don't Joe and you don't he made
it work
yeah ex-man Game of Thrones finale made
it work that's true no Maureen Bushnell
and Chris Lane making it work on door
right go walking goes on tour the Barbie
dad hurts back to always what I say when
two very successful people together get
together one of them has to step back
but Lauren Bushnell hasn't set back she
could do it she does she's in Russia is
ideal scenario where she can work
anywhere Joe and Sophie none either of
them sit back she did x-men premiere in
LA and then came here to New York for
the Jonas Brothers album launch you can
do both she doesn't have to go to every
show with him no no especially at the
first early months their relationship
you should only see the person a couple
times a week you know yeah they have the
means no so she's no longer a wrestler
she's no longer I should be able to make
it work she's really just an influencer
like Lauren B and you do that new
pictures for fashion no bet anywhere you
can influence anywhere
look at snitch she's influencing
everywhere all around the world she
posted the most premium ad yesterday
like I need to be in the magazine no I
know
thanks guys I was literally [ __ ]
their pants are you excited how does it
feel to be an influencer what is your
beauty skincare routine by the way it's
it did you watch it of course
flocks alone honestly that miss was nice
the mist is I sprayed it and then over
here I felt a cool breeze and I was like
is there a sea coming out of
my cabinets and no it was the mist tight
squeeze
cool breeze now you got the now you got
the now you got the she burries what it
shouldn't web are we playing for one
more minute her legs are like sky-high
and I assume that she you know is the
way that she is physically because she
was a wrestler it's been a chance
wrestling yeah maybe you do it's like
the missing piece of my workout routine
even now I think she just like works out
like the rest you know Jesus knew him
like us probably first sure she she's
always over like traveling and you know
you can do new him anywhere and she's on
top of where she seems goal-oriented
right Noom is a habit changing solution
that helps users learn to develop a new
relationship with food through
personalized courses based on psychology
NIMS you should see why you do the
things you do and arms you with the
tools to break the bad habits and
replace them with better ones
they say it's based on cognitive
behavioral approach I just say it works
new ones not a diet it's a healthy and
easy to stick to way of life no food is
good bad or off-limits new teaches you
moderation can be used in conjunction
with many pre-existing popular diets if
you want when noon was pitch to us I was
immediately drawn to the fact that food
is psychological and then when I started
taking the courses I'm like migraine has
been wired to make me eat unhealthy yeah
it really has no it's it's all really
mental you're human if you go off track
there's no shame just tips to help you
get back on track for tomorrow that's
one of the hardest part it's like why
can't you just like [ __ ] up and then go
back no it's like I [ __ ] up I might as
well ruin my life no it's like I have
one bad day might as well burn my week
or sometimes I have one bad snack might
as well ruin my day
but no new has taught me like you're a
[ __ ] human being you're not a machine
robot and you don't have to change it
all in one day steps small steps that
make big progress sign up for your free
trial at noon and oom dot-com slash
toast what do you have to lose visit
Noom comm slash toast to start your
trial today that's Noom dot-com slash
toast the wit the last weight loss
program you'll ever need sign on what do
you have to lose truly anyways you have
to lose you break up in the end that's
this song oh my god totally now I'm
gonna shadow fresh eyes because I would
do it all over even like it's my
perspective on their relationship like I
would go through all of this the highs
and the lows even though knowing they
were
in the end even though totally that
songs about Barbie
I don't know and now I'm feeling like it
was like ah yeah before they determine a
today oh no it's not about me it's about
like the way he feels the way I feel you
know they write songs you know ever
relates to different songs for different
reasons some as a window into someone's
soul exactly but now I'm feeling like
what about snitches window have a nice
sweet ride remembered in Cole Swindell
at the Hudson Alabama we didn't actually
try but we have to go to Lauren Alaina
bad Margo you were also wearing that
dress you need a new dress it's just so
easy
we spoke to Lauren Alaina nothing more
no I have morning without like trying to
set Margo up with it was like Mitzi on
stage don't have 936 it's a few years oh
my we signed Margo up for js5 yesterday
that's so exciting it was it was pretty
disheartening
it was pretty disheartening like there
wasn't anyone for stretch on there it
was really sad ha so hurry I'm gonna
take your phone later cuz I feel like I
can sit through maybe I mean but what's
it like to do I do differently besides
just acts no but just all the different
apps you see the patience it's like a
whole thing yeah and you need to like
look deeper you know into their
questions that's true like Jason you
don't answer questions
no but just the things that the
information that they provide yeah you
know I feel like everything tells a
story even what college you want to it's
like you've chose that college you know
right we found someone yesterday from
Colgate yeah yeah we heard that motherly
heart of them oh that's nice of you yeah
he was gonna Colgate on Jace white mhm
what are the odds so you'll be seeing
Cole Swindell anyways are we done
talking about a whole Swindell Schwartz
Cole Swindell gate code Swartz already
know I'm done talking about it you are
okay we might come back I mean like I'm
only gonna spend time grieving this
relationship like it was a three-month
relationship like I really can't be that
torn up over it you're allowed like 15
minutes I guess I guess I don't know I
just I something about it just resonated
for me know it doesn't always happen
sometimes I'm like how who where when
why makes sense fourth story this is
something I think you're gonna enjoy a
little good news to bring up adventures
uber comfort lets you request extra
legroom and crank up the AC before
pickup uber is rolling out a new way to
request
extra legroom quiet cars and other
amenities that are typically associated
with its hype higher priced uber black
service dubbed uber uber comfort the new
service will be available today in over
40 markets in North America comfort is
presented as a whole new product
category in the app alongside uberx
uberx SUV an uberx own think of it as
fancier than uber X but less fancy than
uber black honestly that's what I need
by the way it's also more expensive
riders can expect to pay around 20 to 40
percent more than a typical uber X trip
according to a spokesperson okay so
you're paying more for extra legroom and
air conditioning and no and those are
both amenities available and in other
cases your seat up and yeah and clicking
I see and I feel like this is one of
those like updates on an app that it's
never actually going to come through
because there's new updates as of like
the last few months when you select a
card you can have preferences now
conversation you want quiet or
conversation yeah air air you have rider
preference and literally every time you
in the car is to say they don't listen
to my preferences right they don't care
but it says uber comfort will have newer
cars with extra legroom the newer cars
is interesting cuz sometimes you get
into an uber and it's like a hot yeah
it's a hot bed of sadness
they're like suede the Suites the seats
are sweating yeah and it's like summer
like hot box if someone else's lunch you
know I went into a bodega today
I sure what I went in I got it and I got
hit with a fog that was so it really
could barely see through it except for
the flies swarming and the place didn't
have what I needed so I left immediately
and I smell like the bodega now New York
is so funny I don't know if they're AC
was broken or that's just how they live
right but I was in shock no it's it's
quite charged it's like I almost
dismantled my hairspray that's how foggy
it was well you know
yeah humidity the humidity it was insane
I was really like taken aback and I was
alone
so sad I'm sorry that that happened to
you did you get what you needed from the
bodega no I didn't but I also couldn't
see oh my god that's so funny
anyways this isn't interesting I don't
feel like it's gonna work but it sounds
like Delta comfort basically like the
same [ __ ] but like a little less shitty
and that's what they should call it
goober [ __ ] but a little less shitty
uber a little less ex yeah
no no a little bit neo it oh it's like
no X Factor that sucks bless you know
they should have it like this it should
be
uber which is like decent uber X which
is like bodega season and then uber
black uber SUV oh where it's like did
any of you guys I'm going to ask you
Jenny if you guys have diarrhea last
night no no I did runs maybe he's from
the spaghetti Pomodoro cousin neither of
us a I didn't need where'd the
fettuccine alfredo you ate it and we
didn't I had one bite of the fettuccine
alfredo what's so crazy okay so we went
to Toys bad we went to Tony's to Napoli
last night which is a chain of Italian
restaurants in the city that I've been
dying to go to and it's just like such a
premium like family-style experience um
and everyone loved the food and I was so
glad and I really like didn't go in so
hard like in like I think I'm an as in
as I could have same um and that's how
when I got home and I had the runs like
I was so shocked and really like a 12
o'clock on the dot I was on the toilet
no I really like tempered myself there I
felt very satisfied like not
uncomfortably full and I didn't get the
runs am i honest a little jealous I
could use the runs me too
but I did have I didn't have to go it at
the restaurant so I don't know which
ones worse
oh that's bad that's bad yeah at least
you got the comfort of your own home
yeah but like I don't know murderously
the bathroom was really nice there it
was it was lovely because they knew they
know I'm sure they have certain
restaurants you know their type their
cream sauce is a little too creamy it's
11 oven meat wish justice ASAP for a
sack rotten true just say that phrase up
yeah get him out of there get him home
are you ready for our next story we have
a lot to do today because we also have
to recap Beverly Hills and we have to
hear toaster yes and we have an
interview with our new 25 year old
co-host
I love interviewing people I think I'm
gonna stay 24
okay now I have some more bad news I
guess it's just one of those negatives
or movies friends to leave Netflix for
Warner Media HBO's Mac streaming service
in 2020 so friends and the office are on
their way out of Netflix nobody cares
about the office people the people who
don't care about friends aren't me
nobody here cares about us no my my
husband will care but I'm actually
excited cuz he's always watching it and
really always I didn't know that about
your new service or designated survivor
well so I mean we've been talking about
this for a while
and it hit me yesterday like after all
the fodder the conversation the
streaming services the debates at the
end of the day what I'm left with is
really like a hole in my heart and it's
like we could talk about it but then
when we think about the actual
realization of not having friends on
Netflix it leaves me feeling deeply
saddened and like really afraid because
I really rely on friends so much and I
always have it on in the background I
feel like it really relaxes me it helps
a lot with my anxiety and I'm just like
now feeling nervous well why don't you
buy all the seasons on iTunes like I
don't have Apple TV on Amazon Amazon you
she just an HBO max that's what I saw
yeah it's going to HBO we had got the
Warner's streaming service now yeah
under a new deal with Warner Brothers
television HBO max will have exclusive
streaming rights to all episodes of
friends so I guess what Warner they do
pay for HBO do you get that streaming
service I need to know the details
HBO max is probably a new thing you have
to pay for or it's part of the existing
I didn't it's part of like HBO GO HBO
nobody some people have HBO go and don't
have HBO now there's definitely just
different tiers what's so interesting is
when I sit back and look at the media
landscape of all the streaming services
I've now realized that I pay for one
service I don't pay for Netflix we have
a family one I use Liz Heights Hulu my
Spotify is actually connected to Ben's
credit card and Facebook because I stole
it from him when we first started dating
Amazon Prime do you pay for prime yeah
you pay at the year whatever year yeah
oh then okay I pay for prime that's it
nice I think I feel like I'm killing the
game I think I would pay for probably
two because Lexie love it I use your
Hulu yeah I'm trying to think what I pay
for nothing now that I got that Lifetime
movie Club free membership a you know a
you know I got free Raising Cane's for a
year
what's that it's a I told you like I'm
on literally a regional chain tour of
America and in the South there's a
like a chain restaurant called Raising
Cane's and it's just like southern
deliciousness and I got chicken fingers
and it came with Texas toast and it was
literally the best bright piece of bread
I've ever had in my life and they sent
me a gift card for free canes for a year
Wow yeah it's like having one of those
police cars yes a TBI whatever it was uh
it was pretty cool pretty special it's
pretty cool ain't it good to be the
couch oh yeah you know what I'm not
interested in Lesley ting I'm interested
in what's coming because I'm really
running dry okay did you see the trailer
for the new Netflix horror movie with
Brenda song yes it looks very good see
that she gets a lemon accident and
forgets her life and her husband comes
to pick her up and takes her back to the
house but like is it really her husband
oh it's the anti rom-com I saw oh yes
bildad's
wait a minute so that movie is coming
out about the girl who made her
boyfriend commit suicide who looks like
Cara Delevingne oh my god she doesn't
care I love you now die that's a great
[ __ ] moon yeah Wow I'm excited about
that yeah so is it Netflix uh it might
be I don't know don't quote me on that
but I don't know I just need some like
of the old-school shows like Oh see
where is that why is it so harshly on
Hulu it's so funny how dynasty is really
checking a lot of boxes in terms of
content for like shows that I really
need and like had when I was a teenager
like Gossip Girl The OC nano2 whanau is
like all wrapped up into Fallon agreed
agreed
it's really like it's also a soap opera
like it's really um it's a multitude of
shows and I think then it needs to be
there has to always be a show like that
going on to satisfy like that cleaning
of like on whatever rich teenager
did you see Liz on set they started
filming season so yeah and like we don't
know about anything about Liam so like
they can't show him and he hasn't story
to anything at office we can't know if
he's in Atlanta or not he's definitely
alive
he's definitely ill he has to be like
would you say what'd happen if he's not
you're done I'm done I just like hate
shows that like make us work so hard for
the people that we love like Blair and
Chuck look if they just got together in
the beginning like it would've been such
more premium experience like watching
them like then watch her slum it with
Dan right no but then you just have to
watch like all that come up it's and
then the show ends and they're finally
together but no
or happy life together being rich of
green like the fact that kool hain is
just like all you have to worry about
him like I hate him I want to call
instead apartment okay I want to see
Liam's mansion meet you yeah he's like
the Vanderbilts that's the only problem
I really have with these shows it's like
you shift to people and you wait so long
to get them together you never get to
see their life together Watson rejoins
the happy time I don't know I don't know
what does he say the water so they're
like together even if they end up
together or not but if they don't even
work right what if she doesn't like his
mother what if they go through all of
this and it just doesn't work out and it
wasn't meant to be what if they disagree
on political issues what is what if I
was maybe just something to think about
Jimmy Gemma - dear toasters here
toasters were hobo huh roba we're hobo
huh okay last night season finale Real
Housewives of Beverly Hills
closing the book on a lackluster season
you know what they did the same thing
they did last year where they had an
event that was made to be the finale but
they didn't get what they wanted to they
made everyone go to Kyle's house yeah
very true because Kyle's swim got a
Beverly Beach they never got to wrap up
fully and take a group picture together
so they had everyone come to Kyle to see
a new house I don't know why they didn't
use what was even the agency 25th office
yeah I mean everyone was there so except
for Lisa and then I guess they had to
like close the book on Lisa and I guess
things change they just wanted like a
status update um I kind of liked how it
ended I loved touted I loved the women
sitting around and like I know on
Twitter I can't look at Twitter I don't
know why I do I just I'm hoping that
like people will have their heads on
straight and will like you know I only
see the light but everyone was like
these women just sit around and talk
about Lisa I'm sure they had a lovely
lunch where they talked about everything
but Lisa and then the producers were
like this is about where you're at with
Lisa
everyone please share your experience
yeah and it was super interesting to see
how many of them have run into her
because it really is such a small town
and the way they talk about her it's
like really felt like the end of like a
90 it's not like the end of like never
been kissed when they're all saying
goodbye after detention and then like
they're like and I saw and you know I'm
really sad about the way things ended
you know yeah like where is everyone at
now yeah I really felt like like a John
Cusack no John Waters moving
yeah you know yeah so I enjoyed it I'm
loving this group of women except for
Camille coming oh no but she wasn't
after lunch I'm saying thank you at that
table everyone was just like so happy
for one another and there really is a
lot of love there and it's interesting
to see how they've all moved past their
own [ __ ] like Teddy and Erica Teddy
and jury like I was learning like
underlying issues where it's like
they're not all best friends all the
time everyone's obsessed with each other
it's left to their own devices on a trip
where they're drunk like they will fight
oh and then watch outside when they give
a sneak peek yes there was the most and
I was thinking this when this happened
and jury L said it's show eloquently
when it comes to propagate and I know
everyone's sick of talking about it but
telling me it seemed like she decided
not to be a part of it anymore but to
read was like when I watched back the
show
you didn't make that decision they made
it for you and then you want to be the
only one standing so you blew up
everyone's [ __ ] something you didn't
wanna do it you didn't want to do it
alone right like you acted like you made
this Cavalier but your decision to take
a step back but no you were kind of
forced into that and that's a big
discrepancy yes but I think regardless
of how she came to the decision like she
did and then she did the right thing
afterwards and I think Teddy has been
very honest about the fact that yes
there was a moment where I was an
[ __ ] there was a moment where I
wanted to hurt you and I got stressed I
was very much in on it and now I can
tell you about what happened when I was
in that moment and who else wanted to
hurt you yeah so I don't think it's a
deal breaker but I'm glad that they're
clearing it up also because Teddy you
know those text messages Teddy needs to
show the beginning of like before that
her text messages with Lisa I'm sure
Lisa doesn't put anything in writing but
Teddy wants to bring some receipts yeah
because she's getting buried bless you
and she's gonna marry by her I feel like
I know exactly what happened like and
that Teddy isn't necessarily lying yes
there was a moment where she omitted
because she didn't want to read to know
the full scale of what they were going
to do to her but now that Lisa brought
it out okay Teddy can can actually share
but she hasn't done that yet and the
people the audience clearly needs to be
walked through it step-by-step because I
feel like when they watch the show it's
like you look at it from afar where it's
like Lisa's mom died like Lisa's brother
died and like the women are being mean
to her and she's going through so much
and like yeah when you look at it it's
like hey what the [ __ ] is that but when
you look at it on a human level where
it's like these women are friends you
know she's not treating them
like friends and lisa rinna said it's so
perfectly like when i've been a part of
this group of my dad died and I didn't
ask for any favors and I got my ass
handed to me at the reunion like you
it's like it's either everyone gets a
free pass or nobody does it so far
nobody does Eileen lost her mom Larry
the day of the reunion yes so Nora
didn't say anything in Beverly Hills no
one gets to pass in Jersey everyone gets
a pass when Theresa is going through it
she gets passed yet all of her behavior
but that applies for everyone else too
fine but in Beverly Hills thus far thus
far and just like the way you don't talk
about the money in Beverly Hills you
also don't get a pass for personal stuff
yeah and like I don't know that that's
seen in vain it was Lisa who was
withholding the passes that yeah is so
rich that scene where Camille is like
her nose is so far up Lisa Vanderpump's
assets about to come out of her [ __ ]
throat in Vegas makes me so mad one
because if can be owned and go to Vegas
they wouldn't have shown any of the
footage and I just couldn't have cared
less about Lisa's grand opening where
she looked like the cheesiest tackiest
Queen I'm gonna throw them like so
[ __ ] stupid I could die second
Camille's like well now that you're gone
I'm the target like oh my god I can't
you're so two years old like relax no
and because you you came in guns blazing
you came for every year being tremendous
twice and you want to act like the
victim like this is truly highschool
know it's crazy but I came into agency
party like a bull in a [ __ ] toy shop
because she spoke to someone in the two
days wild her ah the dinner and that and
I have to believe it was Lisa Vanderpump
and I thought it was so interesting that
they showed footage of her leaving the
restaurant the farmers table whatever
was called leaving the restaurant
apologize and say I feel bad that I said
that like I'm sorry and I just I hear I
hear by I'm inducting myself into the
Denise Richards
stana hood Denise Richards is the MVP of
this season with her coat and no you
[ __ ] back dad and it's like she's so
nice she's so sweet and she's so
carefree
but then when pressed she's so gangster
she's a great [ __ ] housewife I know
that they signed her for four seasons
and I'm thrilled about it know cuz she's
on the right side of history she's well
spoken but she they do somewhat in the
middle yes she's well-spoken makes great
points and like doesn't get pushed
around it's like you thought she was
gonna be like sweet Denise went
meals like being a bull Vaughn and know
she's in her face with her finger and
she picked up to read they have a
blossoming friendship that I'm really
excited about to read this season is my
favorite housewife follow her on
Instagram last night she posts premium
content yep I followed her even before
she was my favorite housewife just
because I love her style
oh my god what she wore to Kyle's house
she look so [ __ ] cute with her doctor
she looks so [ __ ] cute her face look
different and they couldn't put my
finger on it because she wore a red lip
I think in action and she put a headband
with her head bareback two things that
can really change a face no I think that
she had like fresh fillers here because
her lips didn't look bigger but it was
something around her mouth that was
different and it wasn't red lips she
wears the crazy stuff and she always
looks the same they all I think it was
fillers here she's like she looked great
but it took six months off and didn't
put on makeup so that they were so
excited to film that they all brought
their most premium outfits garden-party
Erika Jayne mr. Rd she is this charity
the [ __ ] hair like she looked amazing
Lisa Rinna was turning neon shoes legit
dirts outfit teddy was okay but she's
getting better she brought it was a vibe
it was like a boho vibe her and she's
really dressing so much like I'll yeah
you see Camille say on my chop inside
that last night that Kyle's been so
Debra steady so far up her ass it's like
no that's um Lisa Vanderpump's house no
a hunter isn't I want to talk about what
watch what happens live in a second
anyways I'm this is a season it really
requires a reunion to see where like the
consumers happened fallen because I
don't feel like you know what was going
on six eight months ago on the show it's
not where we are today so we have
different problems oh right so also I
have when I was on the dark hole that is
Twitter I saw an interview that you did
on KTLA and the interviewer guy who's
like I don't know some like weatherman
morning show host was so mean rude to
her and like he I think Lisa Vanderpump
had paid him because he was literally
talking just like her like Lisa doesn't
mean you guys she's the most successful
one on the show who cares if she doesn't
show up and Doreen was like you I think
we said grease like she was like you
said I'm just like Lisa oh good he was
like yeah Lisa doesn't need the show
she's no I don't like that no it was it
was really uncomfortable and I felt
really badly why is Dury doing KTLA
dirty please come to the morning toast
we respect the hell out of it why you
deserve to be treated um I want to talk
about something really scary and I'm
saying it now but I'm pretty sure
Camille's gonna be a full-time housewife
next season
because we can't just have six girls
that get along and then when they do
fight it's painful because I like them
all
we do need villains we do need Brandi
Glanville who's gonna come in and say
stuff but who also has like a good heart
like then she weirdly has like a firm
moral compass yeah and she does isn't
just out to get people she's out to make
good television she's not manipulative
like Lisa Vanderpump in and wipes her
hands clean like she gets an E and she's
not two-faced like she'll she won't talk
[ __ ] about you and be nice to you she
hates you you know it so I think she's
just what the doctor were no I just
don't want Camille to like get rewarded
for being an animal the seasons you
don't even she came in with the most
obvious intentions she was knocked out
all she needs to get back on this show
her life hasn't been the same since
she's been off the show she's been
friend of house side for a while she was
gonna make her bed this season and like
I just don't want her to be successful
in that yes but it's also frustrating
it's nice when we have an outright
villain that we can all agree is the
villain like those day early Danielle
Staub days you know true cuz right now
like I'm so frustrated by the season
because we're all disagreeing on Lisa
versus the girls and I think over like
even Carroll versus Bethany like that
was a polarizing time and I don't know
if that was a great season but this
season we can all have Ares an
incredible suit that LuAnn is out of
control but we are all in agreement and
I I don't know it's no I think it's
always better when the world is truly
divided i know because then sometimes I
question myself I'm like oh it's
frustrating but I'm saying in terms of
actual TV like when Bethenny versatile
like that was really polarizing like I
was firmly on Team Joe yeah like and
that was some of the best TV scene with
Carolyn Bethenny that was like so crazy
in the world was so divided and I've
never felt so emotionally connected to a
group of people that I don't know Carole
Bethenny was easier because I knew I was
Bethenny I didn't have a question in my
mind but sometimes like not that I know
I'm Vanderpump but the timing of this
fight was just so bad that like I don't
feel like this is where I'm gonna stick
my snake in the ground okay but everyone
else decided for us yeah but when you go
and Twitter everyone's in lvg Stan can
we just talk about the agency for a
second and like how really far it's come
and I was like really getting emotional
choked out when Kyle was talking about
like that would be doing date night real
estate license like I was so key I
really love Kyle's family like she like
makes it like that's what I want my like
I feel like I really relate to her kids
I'm like their unity and like all the
daughters like that is like what I want
my family to be like like I really like
they love each other so much they like
work hard they're like not spoiled
because they didn't grow up like that
like Portia
well but like it's cute like I don't
know whether she's a baby like this
engine right I just like real like love
and respect for their family they make
me just want to like pop out some girls
some girls for sure I agree and I just
want to talk about miss fertile that's
Richardson yeah knock on wood she is a
great vagina she I don't know if I'm
fertile I mean like I don't know it's
got you know just I'm always doing this
when I'm talking about yeah you don't
want to jinx no gelded would but
speaking of fertility I would be remiss
if I didn't discuss modern fertility
which is the first comprehensive
fertility hormone test for women that
you can take at home we're waiting
longer to have kids we've got stuff to
do we got tours we got morning shows to
build but it's posing a problem because
one in six couples have trouble
conceiving we've all that we have all
the tools to prevent pregnancy but we
need more information on how to help us
plan for it even if kids are in the far
far future modern fertility gives you
customized reports to help you
understand your fertility through your
hormones you'll have a personal
fertility team to help you understand
your results and make a game plan you
can access to a team of fertility nurses
a weekly webinar and their online
community of women just like you if you
like modern fertility it's perfect for
the average Joe sir because there are so
many toasters in this stage of life
we're either just got married
trying to have babies thinking about
having babies struggling to have kids
and there's like a community online of
toasters who like really congregate and
talk about this and if you like
information is power and mana fertility
is just giving you out information yes
you can take the test at home and you
send in your test get your results back
in a few days it's super convenient
it's cost-efficient proactive fertility
hormone tests often aren't covered by
insurance it can cost upwards of fifteen
hundred dollars at just one hundred and
fifty nine dollars modern fertility
gives you access to the information you
need to help you plan ahead now of
course if you visit we got modern
fertility calm / toast take their
fertility quiz get $20 off your modern
fertility test that's modern fertility
calm / toast
- take the fertility quiz and get $20
off modern fertility calm / toast
knowledge is power we're gonna be given
them a slogan motto fertility knowledge
is power
it really is especially when it comes to
your own body what could be more
important and more exciting more
exciting should be dive into dear
toasters yes I just wanted to make a
note of one thing that happened on watch
what happens live with Camille Tinsley
and Dale Barton a because
out intensely about um dates with Billy
Bush and I was choked with intense I
kept saying that wasn't true and I don't
know Tinsley do world's best liar
no it's doubly true she does run
everything and her mom was just being
like funny mom Thursday like it's
totally true I ship of course New York's
elitist Tinsley Bush but also wishes a
right question I'm sorry for Tinsley
because it's clear that her status on
the show is up in the air based on what
happens at the reunion and I felt like
her going on watch what happens live
last night was like sort of a test like
yeah and she'd be interesting and she
wasn't and I didn't like her outfit or
her earrings I just she always looks
like she's on vacation yes yeah Jackie
that was literally the most I was
thinking the same thing I'm like those
are what you wear out of Miami like no
she's on the beach she doesn't look like
she's made for New York City because my
family says you don't live in New York
City yeah uh yeah Zimmerman like yeah
excuse me get that talus in Olivia in
self-portrait a bunch of theory get back
to theory no I couldn't agree more
um so I just thought I really do like
her as a housewife and I feel like she's
a good addition but I I'm worried about
her yeah like after last night like I'm
worried about her status it's like
Camille confirmed Hirst and Tinsley
didn't Michael Brad like they made it
they made a point to have my Andy read
Michael Rappaport's tweet about Camille
Camille is a housewife through and
through like her or hate her she is it I
don't necessarily agree no me neither
but they they read that tweet online I
know and I usually agree with Michael
Rapaport um I don't actually he says
that Cynthia Bailey's in everyone how so
I'm in the franchise and like I just
couldn't agree less okay
well I agree with him and I just like
how passionate he's just as passionate
as us you know I appreciate his passion
and his like sports metaphors
yeah you know he says she's the Michael
Jordan and his knowledge of the history
he's encyclopedia yeah he brings it back
and then Kenya was truly one of the
funniest things of all time of all time
that will go down and like a watch
happens life history as truly the most
iconic yes okay very dear toasters is
our weekly we try and do weekly and by
segment if you emails to your toaster
says gmail.com we always keep it
anonymous we prefer the quirky ones but
we'll take relationship questions work
questions did your boyfriend donate to a
sperm bank you know lots of different
things so what does her boyfriend have
like a secret sibling and right
found out but he doesn't know hi ladies
longtime listener first-time caller
so my fiance and I have been together
for three years we fell in love really
quickly moved in together six months
later we got a dog and after about a
year being together he proposed I was
never someone who thought they wouldn't
marry ever so this was a big change in
my life plans
I felt so overwhelmed my wedding
planning and this big change that I just
did nothing then three months did the
engagement I got pregnant with my
daughter she was totally unplanned but
it's the best thing that ever happened
to me the pregnancy and becoming your
parents further delayed the wedding
planning but has also shown me that I do
want to be married and make a commitment
to someone
we're not perfect and we argue the way
everyone does but sometimes it would get
out of hand with him not spending the
night or at home or me leaving it for my
parents for a few days or just yelling
at each other every disagreement we
realized we were ruining a relationship
and we have really worked hard at fixing
it and communicating better we turn
things around and we're doing really
well around March we realized we had
seen enough money to throw a wedding and
have been planning it ever since
ever since the weddings in November we
have been fighting a lot recently so I'm
not sure if it's wedding planning is
treacherous
or because we aren't compatible it feels
like he feels like I'm too controlling
and not temp and hot-tempered and I feel
like he's emotionally distant and Kent
can be disrespectful it's gotten to the
point where I feel like I should
consider calling off the wedding if he
fundamentally can't stand that I'm type
A personality why go through all of this
but it's not like I can just breeze away
not only is it going to be embarrassing
to call off a wedding but I'm a
stay-at-home mom and would have to find
a job and save up in order to be able to
leave him I know it's difficult to judge
without directly knowing us but all the
articles on Google about cold feet
haven't given me much guidance so I need
to I need help trying to decide if the
pit I have right now is because wedding
planning is stressing me out or if
there's something wrong in the
relationship and I need to cancel the
wedding yes I know this isn't salacious
like some kinky boss at the office but
it's real life and I know I'm not alone
and trying to discern between normal
wedding jitters and red flag slash cold
feet
thank you for your time wow this is a
great one I feel like you've come to the
right people meet you because I am
firmly in the belief that like wedding
planning ruins relationships and if you
make it through your wedding like you
can make it through anything I can it's
like a distilled life lessons in
communication in finance in budgeting in
arguing like in just in plan in family
relations it's it's it's a crash course
so as someone who had a very treacherous
engage like wedding planning experience
so as well I can understand where you
are and how you feel like you're losing
your mind you just like want to throw
your hands in the air and there's a dip
between that feeling and feeling like
the person might not be right for you
but don't not call it off because of the
embarrassment or anything like that just
like listen to thank you next and like
you'll be fine
yeah I volunteer wedding is like the
most baller thing you've ever so cool
and anyone who ever does it like I just
have such respect for them because I
know that that must be the hardest
decision to make especially when there's
obviously emotions about people involved
invitations and like family deposits
yeah so if anything like don't let that
be the reason why yeah you know I would
just really urge you to like reflect on
the inside and like try and separate the
feelings are you feeling overwhelmed or
do you feel like you don't want to marry
this person this was two very different
things and like I weave me and Ben
fighting like I hate him so much but I
never don't want to be married to him
and like that's the difference and
everyone fights and I feel you guys have
come so far on your relationship the
fact that you were able to work on it
like some of the difficult times like
you had a kid together like it seems
like there's a really strong foundation
there and I don't want wedding planning
to be the thing to do rail like what
could be a great marriage you don't mean
like think about it this way if the
wedding if you weren't planning a
wedding say you guys just elope tomorrow
now all the wedding planning is off
where would you be are you like still
upset it was like book right before the
we got before our wedding like there was
it was crazy like just a million things
every single day like I could lose my
like migraines I was so [ __ ] stressed
out but literally February 18th light as
a feather because all of that for all of
our issues were really like logistical
wedding issues and they were just gone
and that's why I like the first few
months of being married have been
wonderful because it's like so quiet
yeah it's so take out the like figure
out where you're fighting and if it
relates back to the wedding planning
because also like you might be type-a
and he's type not a but that doesn't
mean that you can't if anything octopus
it's a try I'm very tight-knit buoyed by
your type a personality as it relates to
a wedding but you're not always gonna be
planning a wedding but you know marriage
it's good to have someone who's type a
yeah I would just say identify the pit
wear what is the origin of the pit is it
the man or is it the plans yeah manner
blends manner plan okay it was really
good advice I think that's good advice
too and and don't get intimidated on the
flip side like yes you know starting
over is hard being a single mom is very
very challenging but you can do anything
that's true don't be afraid don't just
fall into something because you're
of what the other thing is like if you
firmly make your decision that it's not
for you like pick yourself up you can do
it moms can do it and I have to believe
that calling off a wedding is easier
than getting on divorce agree hundred
percent okay dear toasters I have an
awkward friendship issue that I don't
know how to deal with sorry that this is
long a few months ago and by the way my
college friends to go out with my
boyfriend and his friend the other night
for the night ok wait start again I'm
still it's hard for me to like I know
one time I saw two movies in one day
which was always my dream and I couldn't
focus on the secondly because I was
still thinking about the first one ok I
invited one of my college friends to go
out with my boyfriend and his friend for
the night double-date
it was kind of like a blind setup
everything was going really well and
everyone was getting pretty drunk as the
night was going on after being in a bar
for an hour so my boyfriend lets home
Alex was saying that she thought my
friend was really cute sorry he thought
the boyfriends friend okay Alex
he thought the friend was really cute
right Claire the setup was going well of
Alex and Claire love it I told Alex to
go for it and my boyfriend and I went
outside to let them interact once we
came back inside they were talking and
appeared to be having a good time
then I took Claire to the bathroom to
get a feel for her vibe she thought Alex
was sweet and nice and talked about us
she wanted to find someone like my
boyfriend I have a relationship like
ours but then she was saying how she
doesn't even know herself and how she
might be bisexual everything at the bar
everything at the bar adjacent you were
her her everything at the bar and drunk
pizza was still going good then we go
back to my apartment and clearly it's
down in the couch Alex told me in the
kitchen that he wanted to make a move
and I was like go for it my boyfriend
and I went to my room but after a while
we decided to go out and spy
they were both lying on the couch
talking and drunk Claire said it I feel
bad because you're with my friend I
don't get that keep reading
drunk Claire said I feel bad because
you're with my friend Claire thought she
was Claire thought she was cuddling with
my boyfriend and not Alex Claire was
obviously really drunk and wanted to go
to bed but Alex kept on trying to talk
to her and touch her
I told outs to go home and he left the
next morning Claire just texts me saying
she had fun and left without saying bye
a week later I found out I'm a trip to
Iceland I'd planned with Claire as
canceled thanks to wow air I texted her
and she never responded the only Jim
Claire's talked to me in months now we
have lau air because yeah i went under
it's quick happy Dorothy
it's her and it's Claire mad at me
because she thought I might have put her
in a bad situation with Alex or does she
have a thing for my boyfriend
Claire was gone two small tenors and
brunch with our group and I haven't been
invited I'm honestly confused and want
this awkwardness to be over thanks
confused toaster that sounds awful I
have no idea that was really like
confusing that was really confusing and
I don't think it's either of those
things I think you just happen to hear
that one part of the conversation
imagine if you didn't walk out at that
time you wouldn't know that she thought
it was him so I think it's something
else that she was thinking but like why
aren't you mad at her for trying to [ __ ]
your boyfriend right it sounds like she
was okay with [ __ ] your boyfriend I
don't know I think though you was like I
would just ask her directly because it's
clear that she's thinking something that
you haven't considered because neither
of those things add up I agree
directness is kage big yo [ __ ] what's
going on and also maybe you misheard
like you don't know that Claire thought
that that was your boy you could have
heard of that of context like what are
the odds that of all the hours you're
hanging out you walked out and you hear
that and you're piecing that together
this is what you get for setting people
up just like a friend like maybe so it
is something that you're not aware of
right like maybe it's you know have
nothing it's you but like you know
there's clearly different like chunks
missing I would just ask her straight up
because it sounded like it was a fun
night and you know it's worth salvaging
I agree
next up third and final tear toasters
remember you can email us at ear
toasters at gmail.com okay so here's the
deal my aunt just recently got divorced
from my uncle who happened to have been
cheating on for the last 25 years
so not a Nancy he's a complete scumbag
oh he's yeah so not an uncle's neato
sorry now she has a new boyfriend it's a
little soon but who am I to judge he
seems like a very nice guy and she
decided to bring him on our family
vacation a few weeks ago while we were
there things got spooky first up he
hugged everyone way too much for example
if you saw breakfast you would get a hug
then again at lunch and then again at
dinner oh my god I hate that this is my
biggest pet peeve oh not even a hug but
it was a little odd fast forward to a
few days in my mom the ancestor says her
foot is hurting her from walking on the
beach so while we were on our way to
dinner that night my aunt's new boat
literally grabs my mom's foot in the
card starts rubbing it
my mom was obviously uncomfortable what
kind of laughed it off I'm dying
then the very next day after dinner we
were all sitting around drinking talking
and listening to music when the dude
proceeds to get up from where he was
sitting comes over to my mom and starts
rubbing her feet again I
she was going to die we all just tried
to act casual and not say anything rude
but it was so good
then my aunt's boyfriend leaves vacation
a few days early which at this point was
rather relieving so after he is gone
we're all sitting in the condo talking
and my aunt proceeds to tell us that her
new I can't say it you have to say it
that her new boyfriend peed on her while
they were in the shower together my
first reaction was like wait on accident
but no he literally peed on her and then
wanted her to pee on him I know what
you're thinking my aunt's boyfriend is
not our Kelly however she acted rather
casual about the whole thing and just
kind of laughed it off awkwardly yep
needless to say we're all a little
concerned about this guy we of course
don't want my end to be we want man to
be happy but we aren't sure what to do
do we say something to my aunt or just
like she wants to know do we say
something or not it seems like you're at
like this guy's obviously a freak some
people are kinky like the peeing thing
is we are just being overtly touching
like you're a weird guy but it seems
like she's not super bothered by it
so maybe just let her live like I gotta
be honest of everything that was said I
think the foot thing is the weirdest
part yes then the golden shower is like
not my cup of tea but it is a thing that
people do also golden shower is not
always in the shower at least it was in
the considerate freak yeah he's a clean
freak I'm like so uncomfortable I don't
know he sounds like a freak but it also
something Koreans happy so like maybe
just maybe just stay away from him but
like let her--let yong-chol yeah no he's
not yeah it was about time your family
got their creepy uncle yeah he doesn't
sound like a bad guy he just sounds
weird but it seems like your aunt
doesn't mind right as long as she
doesn't mind the foot stuff and I mean
the hugs is just a personal preference
and the peeing like for Carrie it was a
deal-breaker
maybe for Encinitas it's not and I don't
think that's crazy but maybe just limit
going on vacation with them because I
would want to be but maybe that's also
like a low self-esteem thing when you
find out your husband of 25 years is
cheating on me like you you said who can
become yeah you can become like self
like low on self-confidence and settle
on a freak but maybe this guy just like
wants everyone to like him it's like
he's giving everyone hugs he's right
you're hurting let me rub your feet like
we usually like in the
and like he was just so happy care like
that and just so much he wants the
family to love him too obviously he's a
cutie no I know and then he's a freaking
machine doesn't sound against each this
is having a good time and I'm happy for
her I'm a that I am yeah I would just I
mean I wouldn't sit her down me like are
you okay
I would clean from you know how she is
whether or not she's okay if this guy's
really a freak but let her live it's
been 25 years of yeah let her live okay
so thanks for a great episode merch is
still available and shop until Friday
where do you keep it open till Friday
because people get paid on Friday and we
want everyone to be fiscally responsible
so let's shop morning toast calm get all
your new items we got koozies hats fanny
packs new t-shirts new pop sockets and
then some of the best sellers back in
stock like the classic pop sockets
classic hats a sorority sweatshirts are
finally back in stock selling like
hotcakes to make sure you got one
yeah the sorority sweatshirts are key if
you're a toaster it's just I think it's
the most important item pop maybe pop
socket but this sweatshirt is just it's
vibe and joules occurs flags and we just
have like one more exciting thing to
food it is your birthday and we just we
would be remiss if we didn't celebrate
so we have a little something something
for you it's a box yeah we got a little
cream in a bag what is it you'll see two
boxes pa is on it doughnuts the PA is on
it
just chop her okay he can do that also a
new episode of the Schmitz yes with the
husband from all of our sport is Steen's
bends to her co-hosts were out this week
so we had the husband's fill in so it's
my husband Jackie's husband and Olivia's
husband all talking sports talking the
Derby they talk in the USWNT talk by the
USWNT parade is today like I kind of
want to start at 9:30 a.m. Eastern Time
look how great is only one hour I don't
know I mean if it was delayed then it
might still be going on I could like for
time to have this conversation I'm just
like so excited at the prospect of food
coming my way so if you're into sports
head over to the Schmidt's if you're
available in Spotify and iTunes if
anyone in your life is into sports over
to the schvitz it's a great episode I
actually listen to it and they're so
funny they just have such a good rapport
and it's cool to see all the
brother-in-law's together
happy birthday to you happy birthday to
you
so nice Sofia birthday oh my god happy
birthday oh my god
is it good you're so picky we wanted to
like you guys just [ __ ] delicious so
Claude what do you have planned for your
birthday today
oh if you're listening as a podcast I'm
eating a doughnut like please not yell
at me it's my birthday oh okay I'm just
gonna spend all day prepping for meeting
tellers left oh right I forgot that
that's on deck tonight that it's
probably have lunch too is there any
better way to spend your birthday no
there's not
welcome to the siege County welcome to
the big lids sponsored by their glass
wearing your third love bragging or
flush your titties always I'm a mom what
are all the flavors there's a peanut
butter and jelly filled one the ability
to glaze peanut butter jelly filled that
sounds so good this happy that one this
one yeah this is PB&J and said oh my god
it's a sandwich doughnut plant huh oh my
is it insane ASMR is it good I don't
taste the peanut butter maybe I'll take
another bite oh it's [ __ ] delicious
and I think that once we nut butter -
and then this one I really got two of
them for you because it's like this
chocolate item this one yeah yeah this
is like my dream yeah life is like a box
- don't you never know what you're gonna
get
mmm overwhelming but nonetheless
delicious
do you like a cinnamon doughnut that's
my Oh for sure for sure
this is like such a great day enough for
the podcast yeah I hope you guys turned
it off by now mmm cinnamon nice nice
light right perfect for dessert no yeah
okay well thank you all for tuning in
happy birthday Claudia we love you thank
you for giving us all of your time and
energy and being such a great color by
time oh yeah
no and thank you for going on tour
meeting the toasters just being the
great gal that you are thank you so much
I love you the world a better place we
love you all had to shout more need to
attack home to get your merge join the
coals it's lit mwah
you